[Musique]
autant
pour vous je me suis rendu à carpentras
là bas j'ai rencontré christophe plutôt
niglo le vrai une droite 3 2 nick lowe
c'est un influenceur gitans de 23 ans
qui fait le buzz avec des vidéos où il
se moque des clichés sur sa communauté
les gens du voyage
franchement j'en voyais pas d influence
occitan j'aime pas trop se montrer ils
ont la
courbe à gauche et nous on ne côtoie
pas dur moi je m'en bats les couilles
complet moi j'ai envie de porter la joie
la bonne humeur
dans tous les cas tu seras créé chic et
donc fait ce que toi ce qui te plaît la
jalousie
niglo il vient d'une famille qui baigne
dans la musique depuis des générations
son père c'est flamenco mais lui c'est
plutôt le rap est avec son pote rds ils
m'ont donné rendez-vous dans leur studio
d'enregistrement un mobile-home aménagée
à leur nage
s'ils jouent le jeu derrière si vous
voulez voir ce port tu
là on a le cameroun
et ça cela pièce préférée de vue de tout
le monde la voit ici on passe des
soirées
ne savez
pas ce que vous faites comme si c'est
quoi la musique on va te faire écouter
là on vient de recevoir juste le mix ce
sens là qui doit sortir dans la khl ip
et là on va te faire écouter en direct
ciao
vraiment je n'ai pas écouté
[Musique]
comment tout à fait vous sont en fait
c'est quoi on va on va te montrer direct
en fait là là par exemple on prend une
prod c'est une structure gère des coûts
mené ce coup on essaye de valider à deux
et après une fois qu'on a fait ça ben on
commence à tafer l'écriture en pinçant
sur quoi et tout est à près de là on va
en cabine tu vois on fait yaourt jargon
ça veut dire que tu dis n'importe quoi
c'est pour avoir un temps plein après
une fois que tu as lattes ont plané tout
belle vente commence à écrire et après
on pose dessus
[Musique]
vous avez commencé les gens dans leurs
actes moi moi je n'ai pas commencé par
le rap imprimons depuis tout petit j'ai
été bercé par le flamenco puisque mon
père mois et joue la guitare et
franchement c'est vraiment un monstre et
de là et il m'a appris à jouer un peu de
la guitare mois l'habitat dans le vrai
sens pas j'aimais bien mais au prix au
bout d'un moment et je sais pas ça
c'était l'ancienne génération et ou même
si tu as vu ses coûts des soins j'aime
bien tentante à gratter c'est ma faute
je fasse autre chose du coup je me suis
servi de ça pour eux dit vas-y je vais
essayer de maintenant de faire ce qui
marche bien est ce que j'écoute voix
voilà brut que tu n'y es pas parce que
là l'arrêté de mambo gagné puisque là
c'est juste un lieu où tu vois là c'est
au feeling on n'a rien préparé on va
envoyer sa la cdc petit des petits
démons non à tomber à cet enfant de 6
ans denis chocolat
comme si
c'était moi j'ai l'âge et je pourrais
écrire
j'ai fait un petit danone là je pourrais
écrire si où je suis dit que tu t'es
fait ici non franchement et les méchants
hélène qualité de fonds mondiaux alors
je te jure et pourtant c'est un mobile
home
et enfin tout ça le fus ans pour mettre
des sous de côté le faire ça va vite
quand avait souhaité terminer
mais en travaillant tu fais pas on se
fait dans le sobre et chic je suis
technicien je fais pas
d'afficher sa balle et ils sont
et c'est pour ça que moi d'ailleurs mon
place d'henning l'eau c'est pourquoi
parce que les gitans ils sont enfin à
l'époque du moins jamais comparer tout
le monde l horizon a pris maintenant on
les laisse tranquilles peu cher parce
que c'est plus pareil mais du coup ce
pour ça vous embête petit j'avais une
coupe moi c'était les piques et à
l'école toujours eu 10 et wet un couple
gérait un hérisson et tout du combat mon
surnom c'est devenu en gros les risques
sauf que les récents agitant ses niglo
donc voilà niglo est le vrai puisque
après il utilise le blast du coup j'ai
mis le vrij de souligner mais voilà ni
blu ray n'est pas du
genre à passer au rec
asie mais je leur ai offert posait un
vrai amour pèlerinage les jeunes femmes
comme service et moi c'est pas super g
[Applaudissements]
la nectarine
aujourd'hui c'est donc moi je valide
haussier tuvalu dubaï amour tu vas l'est
pas je suis plus moi
vas-y bon là je pense que
voilà ça tu vois ça tu guérir de la noue
mais moi depuis tout petit même toi tu
dois être pareil chaque fois l'été dès
que des causes qu'on trouve qu'il ya un
peu de famille vous avez quoi comme
chaque fois c'est ça tous les soirs une
grille va bien manger et boire et manger
l'oncle attend un peu cousin même tu
veux manger salami dynamite étaient
bienvenus
et voilà c'est tu veux quoi de plus
or il ya des choses simples de la vie
mais c'est toi c'est bien c'est quoi
justement votre mac devient un mode de
vie chez la liberté ont dressé ce qu'est
ce que tu veux
voilà comme la couleur il est né à
11h11 une grillade à faire des soldes
en vie sur le moment ça profite du
moment où vous avez voyagé aussi vous
êtes
d'accord à ce sujet c'est mon demi-frère
en fait du côté de ma mère ah oui
pourquoi et ça c'est le copain de mon
petit frère tengzhong à joe
hill et pas des gens du voyage il n'a
pas compris
la force du reste avec nous mais reste
il est à l'étude mon mari est différente
chez nous
ça devient ils sont comme nous
non
c'est pas le fait que la famille
[Rires]
parce qu'elles sont cuites ou quoi que
ce qu'on pense
ghinzu
[Musique]
oscillateurs belle chimie
je savais pas maintenant tu sais
la caméra mieux manger je reprenne depot
r ça dépend ce que je veux maintenant
nous sommes en france
même s'ils sont là c'est pouvoir vivre
de la musique quand il n'est pas en
train d'enregistrer les sons niglo un
autre travail le reste de la semaine les
chauffeurs livreurs
alors là moi je n'utilise mais la
musique à fond
tous
obligés
du
[Musique]
car ça va être un kilo ça vaut
un kilo de lait 2 pour toi
la cdp est agricole pour les machines
bon après ils seront mieux tenir puisque
en fait moi la marchandise je sais ce
que c'est un peu mais c'est confidentiel
un peu bas parce qu'à un messagerie a
tellement de voile et où que tu vois les
palettes sont filmés et où je sais pas
ce que sera ce pour
autant non mais là tu vois je la vois le
cif et la signature attaque tous les
jours soit fait des dédicaces ouais
tiens bon week-end à l'air angie
ça fait cinq ans c'est mon premier
métier
enfin bon on pouvait métier après
forains parce qu'avant moi je faisais
j'étais fort bien après que je porte sur
moi j'ai fait ça
voilà tous les jours la musique et à la
salle
voilà mixage et là on peut partir
franchement après
c'est pour
ça que je fais mon travail est enfermé
au quoi
mon salaire c'est entre mille sa défense
a varié avec des fois les heures sur
pourquoi ça entre mille
je ferai les wayana ces temps que j'ai à
manger puis je vis bien
j'ai un toit voilà après ses principales
je demande pas d'être dans le luxe ou
quoi façon tu le vois je suis simple
d'en être ce pas parce que je suis
connue sur les réseaux quoi que je me
prends pour quelqu'un d'autre quand je
peux aider donner la force aux jeunes
quoi je le fais de temps que
moi je testais foraine de gonfler je
tenais le château gonflable ça ça me
régale et ce à la barbe à papa et a pris
part entre le truc qui me régaler encore
plus c'est après la fermeture là la
machine à l'appoint l'âge alliés et là
je fais tout le monde feint je tapais
tout le monde sait que mon nom d'une pas
de après charges qui voyage était comme
ça moi quand j'avais même dit c'est un
tout et j'ai tout fait j'ai rien vu du
coach car la machine ne s'est pas
possible que le minot lagravère puisque
on a un
[Applaudissements]
en fait depuis qu'il est petit nouveau
se déplace de fête foraine en fête
foraine et son père lui a transmis sa
passion pour la boxe
c'est entraînement acharné l'ont mené
jusqu'à être sélectionné en équipe de
france mais après plusieurs blessures et
décide de faire une pause
on arrive à grands pas les boxeurs mon
grand père était professeur mon père
était boxeur j'étais boxeur va s'arrêter
boxeur montupet regretté boxeur bon
c'est vraiment de toute la famille tu
peux pas trouver le plus plu combattants
qui s'il y avait
[Musique]
quoi la boxe et on trouve déjà de base
et on va dire que c'est un peuple qui
sont qu'ils aiment la partie donc en
fait c'est le moyen de canaliser ça dans
le sport je vois pas ce que c'est un
peuple que
environ sur la base de la boxe j'ai un
caractère qu'il est vraiment inclusif et
franchement avec la boxe on canalise tu
vois j'ai vaincu ça fait quand après
quand je chante la salle je
relativise un peu plus son voyage tu
vois car s'ils combinent thérapie ce que
je pense que si je devais pas la boxe
serait carnage
là avec ça je men est moins tu vois
déjà
déjà les a priori des gens les gens qui
manquent de respect parce que le respect
chez nous c'est important
gens qui te dis pas qu'ils te dennig
alors qu'il s'attend pour vous dépassez
connaissent pas ton passé qui savent pas
ce que tu as fait pour être là parce que
tu vois tu le vois de répliquer avec moi
si tu travailles s'assoyait les réseaux
la musique la boxe on n'a rien on n'a
rien sans rien en fait tout ce que tu
fais c'est du travail qui arrivent pas
de la déroute celle là ça n'existe pas
ça
je couvre là les gens qui critiquent et
tout ça m'énerve
les ménages pour la tv sur ce que j'ai
compris un peu là je me voir ça c'est un
protège-dents collector pour danny
glover et une droite pas de la détente à
une pas deux et en plus on leur apporte
un double place à la roue rouge
[Musique]
saturent
dans toute la france
c'est un avant
2022 dans les combats et 2020 quel est
le con duit à présent annulé pendant un
an n'a plus combattu sa reprise cette
année reste années quand j'avais une
vidéo est touchée par les combats
voilà relate m après avoir avancé pour
que faire un peu plus ou très ludique
alain pivert tu vois
nantais qui inquiète les gold ainsi que
pour le sac ainsi commence à filmer
récemment posé un mini maxi golden pour
boire des bières est dans la tête
[Musique]
paul bigard
les entraîneurs officiels chinois ce qui
est déjà le début premier va enfin
commencer déjà à m'entraîner
[Musique]
oui parce que lyon regarde des films de
jean claude van damme voulait que je
sois ici comme ça donc il écarté jeunes
indépendants comme ça je pense que dans
le décor j'écris depuis tout petit sur
la souplesse
comme ça qu'il a fait de moi ce que je
suis aujourd'hui
[Musique]
et aller où la cassette de bourse elle
était prête à rire un bébé petit boss
aux palois tu vas voir c'est sorte
boxeur
acheté à travers toi c'est bon
[Musique]
gala de boxe pour les petits
c'est très symbolique et il avait invité
tous les clubs du coin g au t
l'udc et le petit gap à ceux-là il a
hélas vivant
[Musique]
et déjà il avait pas peur
[Rires]
c'est parfois qu'elles sont petit
commence à américaines qui vont toujours
rester comme ça même tu sais pas quoi
mais maintenant tu aimerais tu
t'imagines le pape qui sont grands comme
on sent là ce que je regarde on dirait
que c'est y observer c'est payerne
séverine
shing prison même le chien il a nombre
de boxeurs et gones et là-bas garde mais
lui il a entraîné un
trio la voilà on l'a su faire de la
compétition
[Rires]
vous cherchez pas lire et à écrire et je
voulais pas moins que mes petits il
sachant pas lire et à écrire ni rien ils
sont et littré donc comme sa maman
l'avait fait déjà 2 les cours d'eau du
gua j'étais sévères sont l'école moi il
fallait pas rater l'école faire les
devoirs ça les a menés à des diplômes
tous les deux aussi est-ce que vous
pouvez montrer
ici c'est le terrain de mon appel que
c'était une jeune catalan et à ma
grammaire et saint john de famille est
la faute et c'est mon cousin qui
habitent ici est une de mes tantes
capital
conséquent le mobil home
c'est son fils qui habite
tu vivrais après avec des étrangers
c'est pas pareil mais la famille on est
on est un peu solidaires on nous les
gens du voyage où que ce soit et même
les poignets c'est là regardez moi je
vis dans mon terrain ici à ma fille qui
habite voilà ça c'est son camping et ça
c'est sa
caravane tout équipé c'est juste pour
faire manger ta voix telles la vaisselle
tard on ne s'appelle le sèche-linge les
frigos tout ça fait qu'il faut un fusil
ndola en moins ça semble pas le manger
dans la caravane
après tu allais l'état déjà ils m'ont
dit romain comment ils font pour vivre
dans des petits des petits campings
comme ça que tu as ils ont des grosses
maisons tous à melloussa qui on est
toujours dehors
d'aller dans les campings on n'y vit pas
vrai on y va pour dormir pour manger
s'il fait froid ou ou s'il pleut mais
sinon la plupart du temps on est on est
dehors en fait le contrat nous servent
juste à se coucher quoi
à se doucher et voilà comme tout le
monde
prédit tout se passe bien alors moi à
moi tu sais pas quoi qu'il en ferme
vivre en maison jamais de ma vie je
mourirai en camping car
[Musique]
dans la vie la liberté sa liberté
puisque henry la même koné sédentarisés
tout en sentant que je veux je veux je
veux tu veux partir je prends ton l'état
tel ton camping tu vois je ne sais pas
combien de temps tu vas prendre ta
maison tu peux pas les embarquer c'est
cette liberté et en plus comme tu dis
t'es pas enfermer tout emplois créés
entre les murs est où là on a les
campings mais vu que les campings c'est
que fait que pour dormir pour se laver
et on mange dehors en reste dehors c'est
bien j'apprécie la vie quand un tat la
nature total échos qui chante des
cigales
le message que j'ai envie de faire
passer c'est que nous on est tous
pareils même que tu viens caravane je
viens mais sur quoi que ce soit
la nouvelle génération je parle de nous
on est contre toute la jeunesse de
maintenant ne paralyse pas parce qu'on a
des coutumes ou quoi que les gens faut
qu'ils nous voyons arriver puisque
maintenant on a évolué on est encore
peut-être plus dans le game mots avec
les vidéos tout que certains de 3,2 de
la jeunesse qui combine qui ne sont pas
de nature
vous avez british ou vocale et plus je
connais mon restaurant pas de riposter
god de nos fautes au sol tmax une pas
deux ou tu connais mon avance pose avec
british ou vocale but je connais marc a
cependant pas de répit protego de nos
bottes au sol tmax une toiture du
connemara
lna
si de verre de rosé
[Musique]
gitan dans le même village
la salle fait les réglages en fait son
pot propos les gens du voyage
tous les ans la communauté des gens du
voyage se retrouve aux saintes maries de
la mer pour un pèlerinage et célèbre la
sainte sara mais depuis deux ans
l'événement a été annulé à cause du coc
vive et pour la première fois cette
année les gitans de france et d'ailleurs
se retrouvent pour accompagner leur
sainte jusqu'à la mer
vitrine
cela
ça tard aux alentours
marivaux simple
pour le pèlerinage donc là on a une
bonne heure donc ça va on a pu se garer
mais après ça va être la zone
passer un message de paix et en grèce a
commenté le rapport du bon pour pour
toute la nuit tout
ce qu'on sait tous protégés c'est comme
ça là tu vois ça par exemple ça tu feras
pratiquement tous les gitans qui sont
croyants et l'on sait en vo c'est
pourtant levé du le mauvais oeil et gère
se protège toi
et pourquoi c'est important si
tu peux quand même mais agissez pour le
long de l'année certificat bonheur mais
toi tu crois que tu crois passé
c'est comme les musulmans leur but c'est
d'aller l'amex et ça
ne s'est pas notre but parce qu'on peut
aller souvent c'est à côté mais ce match
aller
vas-y fauconnier mais là on va faire un
tour au sein de kobe loups ont marché et
tout
ça tu vois ça ses couleurs la sacem
drapeaux et en saas représente le ciel
ça c'est la terre tout ce qui est la
nature et ça c'est la roue de la
roulotte et ça c'est un drapeau jetables
les communautés du zinc voyage des
communautés roms sintis tout tout tout
ça c'est cela le drapeau
voilà exactement
jamais mené sa peau est tous là
à l'elysée
[Musique]
je m'en
allais pas du droit je connais
surtout les jeunes toit est allé jeunes
comme ça et tout ça la nouvelle
génération salah est suivie sans se sont
connectés sur le gazon se connecter sur
les réseaux
a du coup c'est bien ça fait plaisir il
fat tu connais
une droite pas du tien entre tous
[Musique]
miklos les autres
c'est bien quand mon émotion et
plus exactement qu'on n'est pas que ce
que certains veulent montrer l'internet
c'est grâce à ce qu'il dit c'est ce
pouvoir là pour presque une vidéo
j'allais gagner
[Musique]
et
aucune rue aucune route
apparemment je vois qu'avec un il
apporte à la mer quand tu touches sarah
la tombola pour toute l'année
[Musique]
et
oui
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
mais distant le séga
[Musique]
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
intéressé et si vous voulez voir
d'autres contenus c'est sur la chaîne
youtube de brut à bientôt
[Musique]